皆様ほねほねザウルスご存じでしょうかどういうものかといいますとよされに簡単な
プラモみたいなものです8種類の恐竜が入ってて
お腹に鞍馬でみたいのが入ってるんですけどこれを組み立てて恐竜を作りますがこれも
めんどくさーこんな感じでこんな形で恐竜が入ってるほねほねザウルスなんですけど
要項を見てくれ組み換えがったり自由自在たくさん集めて自分だけの金をね
サービスを作ろう
と夕食でキャンプ集めましたというので今回はこの本で本音頭悪そうに100個集めた
ので自分だけのほねほねザルトスってみようと思います
昔からの夢だった惚れ目指すからの夢だった骨今ザービス昔から好きだったんですけど
1巻やりたかったよこれ1回やりたかった100個分のパーツを集めてどれだけ強力な
こんなことじゃんですが作れるのか
実際にやってみようと思いますでは以降コランスブロットみたいにつくんですよ
やっぱりほねほねザウルスさんで画期的だと思うこういう感じでさっき出た恐竜ですが
ね検討は元せてるんでというパンツがものすごいではあるので一晩で全部出しましょう
めんどくさ
これやばい何時間道路戦いだなこれ多分
これ今日一 is できるのかなぁこれなんか無理な気がしてきたんだけど
ニャー
これたぶんで100個買うように計算されてないと思う
だめだよ貴方恐竜じゃないよ
ちょっと時間がかかりすぎるのでだいたいこんな感じですね組み立てるとこんな感じに
なることがわかったと思いますあんちょっと組み立ててると混ぜた分1日終わっちゃう
ねパーツだけ払っても払っとします組だけません pi 5
手袋手袋つけよう
ああ
me ん
ああああああ
ふっ
ヒューズっとなぜだなーやばいこれは一律10%ほねほねザウルスしか触ってないん
ですけど
まってこれマジできついんだけど
4や2年ここをない場合れた絶対楽しいですパクさんやればた僕が好きなように作って
いいんだ今我慢と平皿ここを乗り越えるしかない
ここを乗り越えれば最高ぜ
頑張りをストレスだぞ
なあそう
でキター
ran
の
範囲
ターってで無事ほねほねザウルス100個開封しました
ちょっともうほんとにめっちゃ草地眼科が動画めっちゃ時間かかりました
2に1個作ったらこういう感じのほねほねザウルスができるんですけども
そのパーツ雷は全部ここにあります a これちょっと普通いては面白そうなんだけど
いやちょっと今回はちょっと苦痛の海だったマジにつらかった
忘れません
今日はここまでにしよ初度もマジできついステで次回はこの部分での外しておくんね
先端のパートを使って収上最強のほねほねザウルスを作ろうと思いますじゃん
ちょっと休憩